you have strong women in your family I
heard that actually your grandma escaped
the Nazis in France yeah that's rad I
know she oh she's incredible she
actually passed away has recently passed
away but she's French Marinette and um
yeah she was 11 years old lived in
France when during the second world war
and and the Germans took over her home
and she was on the road she was bombed
at she went on this Mass kind of Exodus
to Paris so her story is it's just so
incredible i' sit with her and you just
realize what she lived through and had
been through and I mean would you ever
make a film about that cuz that seems
pretty great I know and she wrote down
so my grandfather she spoke all all her
memories and my grandfather wrote it
into like a small book so it is
something I would love to do one day
yeah I think that's amazing especially
if you have like your own production
company and you can like really take
hold of it the ownership is your family
yeah exactly you would have to be really
precious and take care of it and make
sure it right but and you could play
your grandmother that's like amazing and
I want to shout out to my other
grandmother as well American actress
just incredible Helen Horton the most
glamorous powerful woman oh God so you
from just a
powerful a good
breed that's amazing yeah and now I want
to shout out to my mom cuz she'll be
like you always mention your
grandmothers my mom's amazing too Mom
you are amazing mom well done mom I get
I get that my mom would totally so do
you are you like the family heirloom
type do youall have a we I didn't know
anyone in my family so I have like
barely anything from my family are you
the type to keep stuff we do have
heirlooms we do well there's like I but
I'm so sentimental I'll keep anything
like a tiny note that someone's written
to me once it's like all stored away I'm
such a hoarder I am the complete
opposite of you I wish I was like you
well I feel like we had the moment and
then you let it go right you've got to
let go cuz I am like my emotional state
becomes chaotic if there's a lot around
I like simple like yeah I'm chaotic oh
my God I need to learn no I am chaotic
that's why I need it like I mean I do
like like nck exist to some point but
like it's yeah I get overwhelmed but I
we don't really have a lot of family
heirm so yeah that's cool
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home